bonsoir alexis merci d'être avec nous un
rapport de police qui montre un système
frauduleux au sein du rn rapport
expliquant dans le détail comment le
parti a détourné près de 7 millions
d'euros au nom à son profit c'était donc
la une du journal du dimanche de quoi
mettre en difficulté une sérieuse
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
à un an du scrutin que faut-il en penser
oui clairement on a l'impression que
cette affaire sort à un an du scrutin
pour mettre en difficulté marine le pen
c'est une affaire qui n'est pas nouvelle
comme elle le dit elle-même le parti
leur assemblée nationale a tout fait
pour ralentir la procédure à la fois
avec valero de saint-just son trésorier
marie le pen et le parti également l'
enquête du coup est arrivé à terme
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y aura un
procès ou des audiences avant la
présidentielle avant mais 2022 donc de
toutes façons ça ne changera sans doute
pas la donne si ce n'est dans l'opinion
publique
maintenant on va parler de l'affairisme
de la façon dont leur rassemblement
national à utiliser les fonds européens
pour l'enrichissement de marine le pen
et du parti elle parle de calomnie du
jdd organes du pouvoir de tf1 qui même
fait de la fecq news
elle va se défendre évidemment comme il
se doit et puis on a l'impression qu'il
ya des affaires qui attire plus
l'attention de certains médias que
d'autres je ne sais pas si le journal du
dimanche avait parlé de la sphère des
emplois fictifs du modem au parlement
européen de françois bayrou de la même
façon c'est cette affaire qui avait
empêché françois bayrou de devenir
ministre de la justice
il n'avait été que comme ministre un
temps ça n'empêche pas aujourd'hui
d'être encore un allié puissant du
président de la république emmanuel
macron et pour 2022 est actuellement
pour sa majorité est d'être le haut
commissaire au plan
nommé par emmanuel macron donc on voit
bien que six affaires politiques il y a
elle est à relativiser compte tenu des
autres affaires mais clairement elle est
utilisée pour diminuer l'influencé de
marine le pen dans cette pré campagne
électorale
effectivement le prendre l'ampleur elle
a quand même fait la une de ce journal
très lu du dimanche
clairement alexis la justice peut-elle
jouer les trouble-fête parce qu on
souvent
souvient de 10 lustres précédent comme
en 2017 n'est ce pas avec un certain
françois fillon oui c'est clair que la
campagne de 2017 avait été marqué par
cette affaire fillon à faire de l'emploi
fictif de pénélope fillon les costumes
également qui avait fait exploser en vol
le candidat à la présidentielle des
républicains et ça c'est pas vraiment
delà de la politique de haut vol on ne
parle pas d'idées on parle d'une
campagne vraiment des dégoûts de base
oeuvre où on va aller chercher les
affaires au moment opportun pour les
faire sortir pendant une campagne
politique pour discréditer un candidat
dangereux et là on voit effectivement un
peu les mêmes ficelles se mettre en
place avec marine le pen d'un côté avec
aussi jean luc mélenchon qu'il ya
d'autres procédures qui sont en cours
qui ne n'ont pas encore été arrêtés des
épées de damoclès comme ça un peu sur
chaque candidat mais aussi au sein de la
majorité
on a l'impression que faute de bilan
emmanuel macron pas se contenter d'une
campagne de manipulation pour arriver à
ses fins et assurer sa réélection en
2022 parce que c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui le bilan est maigre
même si l'annoncé faire une tournée en
france un tel un touriste au sein de son
propre pays pour commencer cette
campagne
tout ça va être extrêmement compliquée
dès à présent alors tous les coups vont
être permis pendant un an ça veut dire
ça y at il un risque de manipulation via
une justice politique
alors oui cette campagne malheureusement
risque d'être extrêmement manipulatrice
extrêmement propagandiste on le voit
déjà les grandes manoeuvres au sein de
groupes médiatiques
on voit aussi la façon dont certains
médias s'aligne sur tel ou tel candidat
candidats préfèrent aujourd'hui par
exemple instrumentaliser les régionales
pour commencer a déjà enclenché cette
campagne présidentielle et on ne parle
pas de programme regardé que ce soit à
gauche quand on parle d'union de la
gauche on parle de personnalité il faut
faire une plate forme programmatique ne
sais pas où tout cela va aller et quand
on parle à droite on voit bien que les
élèves sont en train de s'inquiéter
d'une possible explosion en vol
avec d'un côté une partie qui voudrait
aller au rassemblement national
peut-être et l'autre qui se demandent
s'il faut rejoindre
en marche typiquement en région paca
avec les grandes manoeuvres autour de la
de la liste de renaud muselier